is giving spotify a run for its money
over its drama with joe rogan yep the
video platform offering mr rogan 100
million reasons for his podcast to move
matching rogan's exclusive deal with
spotify of a hundred million bucks all
right our next guest company locals uh
merged with rumble just last year and
let's bring in the hosts of the rumor
report dave rubin dave did you come up
with this idea that joe rogan might be
perfect for rumble
yeah i did come up with the idea it was
sunday night i was sitting at dinner
with the rumble team we were all talking
about what we can do to help joe rogan
because nobody thinks that joe rogan is
honestly a racist joe rogan is a
comedian who has long-form conversations
with people all over the political aisle
nobody thinks he's a racist this whole
thing is complete nonsense we all know
it's complete nonsense yet the machine
just keeps it going and we're sitting at
dinner and i said to everybody around
the table hey guys why don't we do
something crazy can we offer him 100
million bucks and believe it or not
chris the ceo made a couple calls the
lawyer was sitting there and next thing
you know we put the thing together we
got it out monday morning and joe if
you're watching fox right now the offer
is a hundred percent legit and i'll even
go a step further maybe it's just our
first negotiating point it is legit we
want to deal you back in we believe in
free speech well so
you're at 100 million would you go 200
million
[Laughter]
well that's for the
lawyers and accounts to deal with i'm
just saying i'm just saying we're here
we can meet you somewhere
have you heard from him right has he
responded uh
we have not heard from him directly yet
but obviously he knows of the offer and
and joking aside it is for real and we
all need to fight everyone knows joe
rogan isn't a racist everyone knows
cancel culture is out of control
everyone knows that free speech our
ability to communicate with each other
honestly and debate topics whether
whether it's covid or crt or whatever it
might be all of that is is being
attacked right now and without our
ability to communicate like we're doing
right now we don't have a country we
don't have a place that people from all
walks of life can come to and exchange
ideas and build a better country for
their children so that's what we're
fighting for right now and i hope rogan
will at least consider the offer we're
trying it's our best foot forward truly
so you know donald trump came out
yesterday and others he should not be
apologizing you know he you got to stop
apologizing here's what joe rogan said
you know in a lot of ways like all this
is a relief because it's like just
because that that video had always been
out there right it's like this is a
political hit job and so they're taking
all this stuff that i've ever said
that's wrong and smoosh it all together
right it's good because it makes me
address some that i really wish wasn't
out there you should apologize if you
regret something i do think you have to
be very careful to not apologize for
nonsense correct
dave
do you think he should have apologized
look joe has to do what's right in his
heart as anyone else would have to do in
this situation do i honestly believe
that he thinks he's a racist of course
not do i honestly believe he thinks he
did something wrong i don't think so but
we just don't know what pressure was
brought to bear and we don't know what
it's like to most people don't know what
it's like to sit in a board room with a
bunch of people when you have a 100
million dollar contract and all the
other pressure and you know you got a
wife and kids and you've got family and
people you're supporting and all of
those things but joe is right in that
you should not apologize for things that
you did that you did not do that were
not intended to be wrong and there are
far more uh racist people out there real
quick guys i've got 10 liberals right
here i wrote them down this morning 10
liberals who have all been in blackface
that are still mainstream liberals we
got justin trudeau he's got problems up
in canada jimmy kimmel he's on abc every
night jimmy fallon sarah silverman
howard stern ted danson lady gaga joy
behar on the view ralph northam and
alyssa milano so they've all been in
blackface why are we not destroying them
and i'm not for destroying them but a
little cancel culture equity perhaps uh
that would stop this
dave rubin the host of the reuben report
as heard on rumble where i hope he too
got the hundred million dollar deal dave
thank you very much i didn't know i
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell